as Hannity has explained many times on
this show Paul Manafort trial has
nothing to do with Russian collusion
joining us now with the reaction is the
author of why we fight Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka
Judicial Watch president tom Fitton
and former assistant US attorney
Victoria tensing all right good evening
everyone I want to start with you
Sebastian you know this whole idea of
security clearances I mean we all know
that you don't have a right to have a
security clearance you know Brennan is
kicking and screaming that he's losing
his First Amendment rights as if he's
going to stop talking and it really
isn't courtesy of professional courtesy
so is this guy entitled to a courtesy of
any sort I don't care who the president
is judged I don't care whether it's a
Republican I don't care whether it's a
Democrat I don't care whether it's an
independent the fact is why should
anybody who's left government service
maintain a clearance for the rest of
their lives the viewers should
understand that every security clearance
the first investigation just the first
one costs you the taxpayer $25,000 and
then we expect sebastian here's here's
the argument that they make and and and
there's a way i understand it and that
is there is institutional knowledge so
if a new head of the CIA comes in and he
says you know let me talk to somebody
who's done this before not that Mike
Pompeo is gonna want to call Brandon but
but that is the argument you know
whether it's a new DEA coming in or a
new CIA you know does that make sense
though but no it doesn't even that one
doesn't make sense why what happens to
John Brennan what happens to james
Woolsey if they leave the position of
Director of CIA and they are read out of
the programs and they lose their
clearance does their institutional
memory suddenly fall out of their ears
of course it doesn't if if their advice
if their counsel is requested by their
successor in this administration
I can guarantee you judge nobody
to ask John Brennan's advice because he
voted for the Communists in 1976 and
he's still doing the work of Putin if
they want to talk to him they can invite
him back he can sit in ask if he can
tell you well back in 1980 whatever the
clearance is irrelevant to the question
of institutional memory well and you
know tom Fitton that yeah I'll go to you
I mean you're fighting to get
information but let's stay in the top of
the clearance Hillary Clinton exposed
classified secrets on her email and
that's according to Jim Comey like an
open orchid according to that Romanian
hacker gusoff ur so why is she still
walking around with her security
clearance so why isn't she on that list
of wantons
citizen that's that's a good question
whether she has one or not is an open
question frankly but you know the idea
of a courtesy national security
clearance it tells you that it's not
about national security it's it's about
political rackets here in Washington DC
where these former officials keep their
security clearances has a part to use as
part of their resume to increase their
value to their next employers is nothing
to do with national security it's an
indication of swamp politics the way
things work and it was a brilliant
anti-corruption move by the President to
take on Brennan here and I hope he just
he does go down the list and frankly we
should reform the whole system once you
leave government we have no more need
for you not working for the government
anymore you're not a contractor you lose
your national security clearance doesn't
mean we don't appreciate the prior
service but we move on to protect the
national security walking around out in
the street with no government business
you know of any organization Tom doesn't
get to go back into the company and
check everything they want to know about
it once their time is up their time is
up but Victoria I mean if you've got if
you've got these people who keep their
clearance so there's no question they're
monetizing their the politicizing
Consultants advisers lobbyists MS and
them and CNN consultants or Talking
Heads
but is there a sunset period where it
automatically and I know you represent a
lot of these people who have clearances
over the years you
they're a sunset do you then fight to
keep it judge why I am the only one on
this panel who has a clearance
I have top-secret clearances right yes
and this is to answer your question
because it depends and I have had
representation of people from the CIA
and most recently my uranium one Doug
Campbell client and so I had to have
top-secret clearances in order to be
able to talk with them and so it depends
on what you're doing I don't know I
don't know do you need a top-secret
clearance to do your job because that's
the job Brennan is doing right now he's
commenting on TV I don't think he needs
it for that what but what about everyone
else I mean you know why let's talk
about and I'll go to you said you know
Bruce or this guy's back channeling
information from a guy who is let go by
the FBI and it was a good friend of his
wife who works for the organization that
made the dossier and he's channeling
this information from the from steel to
the DOJ I mean why is forget about
security clearance why is he even
working in the Department of Justice
there's one reason and one reason alone
as you are well aware there are certain
administrative things that you can do to
somebody who is in government employee
that you can't do to them once they've
been fired
that's the charitable excuse but my my
my advice is very simple to the
administration everybody like Brennan
like clapper like McCabe who have
demonstrated their partisanship should
be stripped of their clearances
forthwith anybody else on that long long
list it's not just the list Sarah
Huckabee read it's a much longer than
anybody whose fingerprints whose
fingerprints are on uranium one on FISA
gate on the Adnan maskings and I mean
it's why isn't he doing it well I think
I think he gets I'll tell you what
look there's a certain there are certain
individuals in the council to the
president's office who are more lawyers
than they are political professionals
and they don't understand the costs to
national security of not stripping these
people of their security you know what I
will go to you Victoria
Sep just said something that that is
very interesting and that's a lot of
these lawyers in the Oval Office you
know when they're saying you can't do
this you can't do that well what do you
think well I think that's going to
change because I think the president has
found a shiny new toy and that is
something else it can do in addition to
pardons that nobody can stop him from
doing notwithstanding the silly people
on the hill and say they're going to
pass some legislation that stops him
from taking away clearances they can't
stop him that's an executive authority
and I think he's found it that it's
tweaking people and particularly people
that he wants to tweak and it's going to
continue unabated
I predict okay and tom Fitton I mean now
you've got Bruce or who clearly is
violating all of the rules of the FBI
and the DOJ as it relates to sources so
why is Muller not investigating them and
I heard someone today say well it's
supposed to be about the election well
this is about the elections about Bruce
or working with Fusion GPS who's and his
wife is making money off infusion he's
not declaring that money in his
financial disclosure he's conflicted I
mean why isn't Muller looking at him
instead his mother's taking the
investigation or the information from
him well that there's your problem
you've got Muller using bruce ors
information Christopher Steele's
information that the Clinton DNC dossier
using that taking that whole Obama
Clinton operation targeting at Trump and
and running with it
look this Justice Department is
attacking the presidency through the
Moller operation saying that he hasn't
had the right to fire the FBI director
and investigating him for that now
they're messing with his ability to
conduct foreign policy if I were the
president I will come in and tell the
Justice Department either you stop it
and if you refuse to do so I may go to
court to get it stopped because right
now you've got an out-of-control Muller
investigation we
see where they're going with manna fort
where they're willing to break every
rule in the book to get someone who's
not even involved in Rasha collusion
lord knows what else they're willing to
do to get President Trump well you know
in Sebastian maybe you can just put a
period on that one because clearly
you've got these guys involved in the
run-up to the election their jobs they
violated the rules and they you know too
many they've committed obstruction of
justice by creating this false document
and lied to the court why is Muller not
looking at them I'll tell you why
because the day before Muller was
appointed special counsel by his best
friend rod Rosenstein he had an
interview in the White House
- which rod Rosenstein escorted him in
which he wanted to get his old job back
as director of the FBI yeah Robert
Muller wanted his old job back and he
failed he crashed and burned and the new
president said no you're not going to be
the director I want new blood after i v
Comey and what did rod Rosen Stein do
the next day he appointed this man a
special prosecutor against a man who he
had failed in front of during his job
interview that is the biggest conflict
of interest this is a revenge operation
Bob there's a legal reason also that
this is happening and it's away rod
Rosenstein drafted the authority that he
gave to Mueller he said anything any
leak that you find between the Toronto
campaign and the Russian government he
did not give an authority to Muller to
go into the Clinton campaign or anything
to do with this
the DNC but what the book should be
invited Muller should be investigating
himself he's a witness in this case it's
an absurd and it's incredibly absurd to
have him run this investigation given
his personal involvement in the
underlying facts of the case and the
Justice Department tomorrow night in my
open cuz we have to go guys I'm going
after him parole is complex